AJA HAMMERLY: In
today's "Cloud Minute,"
I'm going to show
you how to view audit
logs on Google Cloud.
From the Cloud
console home page,
click Activity in the sidebar.
Now you can see all the
activity on your project.
You can use the
filters to restrict it
to certain types of activities,
such as just configuration
changes.
By default, viewing data
access logs is turned off,
but you can turn it on here.
To see the data
access logs, you'll
need the private logs
viewer IAM permission.
You can also restrict your logs
to just a specific resource
type, like GCEVM instances.
Or you can filter by email.
You can even see audit
logs across projects,
if you need to.
Audit logs can also be accessed
from Stackdriver logging
if you want to create alerts
based on certain activities.
I hope this helps you
keep track of your system
more efficiently.